determina el dominio y el rango de la
relación dada por la tabla y aquí nos
dan una tabla muy bien entonces nos
piden determinar para empezar el dominio
le voy a poner por aquí dominio dominio
el dominio de esta relación y el dominio
de una relación y bueno también de una
función que es algo un poco más
específico que una relación el dominio
es el conjunto de valores que podemos
pensar como entradas de la relación en
este caso los valores de x son los que
representan las entradas lo que podemos
meter a la relación entonces en este
caso serían menos 133 este 3 repetido es
lo que causa que la relación no sea una
función porque asignados valores al 3
entonces sería el 3 el 3 el 4 y el 6
vale entonces vamos a escribir esto el
dominio el dominio sería igual a y
tenemos que copiar esos números menos 13
el otro 3 ya no lo tengo que poner
porque esto es simplemente un conjunto
346 y aquí se termina el conjunto las
llaves y estás indican que estoy
haciendo un conjunto de números vale
bueno este es el dominio de la relación
ahora tenemos que dar su rango el rango
es las salidas que tiene la relación o
bien la función después veremos que una
función es una relación pero es una
relación digamos que se porta bien vale
bueno ahorita lo que nos interesa es que
el rango tiene que ver con los valores
en ye que puede tomar entonces le voy a
poner aquí rango rango de la relación y
aquí sería igual a podría poner estos
valores ordenados pero en un conjunto no
importa si los valores quedan en cierto
orden o en otro nada más nos importa qué
elementos tiene entonces los voy a
copiar así igualito entonces el rango
sería 3 - 2
288 y menos 1 los elementos de esta
columna muy bien con esto ya logramos
determinar el dominio de la relación que
es el conjunto de entradas el conjunto
de posibles valores en x y el rango de
la relación que son los valores en y que
los pensamos como las salidas o los
resultados de la relación